Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Auf Wiedersehen!
Für's Zuschauen!
Ja, wir kommen da bald noch zu den CDNs. Aber vorher wollte ich noch auf deine Frage zurück. Da hast du ja erst gefragt, was man, wenn man so einen Server mit seinem Blog, das man hosten möchte, dahinstellt, dann optimiert man auf andere Kennengrößen. Da würde man üblicherweise nicht sich da so jetzt mehrere Dutzend Ports, also rein physikalische Ethernet Ports, in seinen Rechner rein patchen wollen, sondern würde man eher eine Platte wollen. Eine Platte ist ganz nützlich, wenn du so einen Blog betreibst, wenn du so einen Router hast, wo so ein Cisco-Betriebssystem draufläuft, was dann Pakete in die Gegend verteilt.
Worüber redest du gerade?
Ich rede darüber, was du für Hardware üblicherweise ins Rechenzentrum stellst, wenn du auf der einen Seite routen möchtest, einfach nur um dein kleines Rechenzentrum selber autark ans Netz anzubinden oder wenn du einen Blog betreiben möchtest. Oder einen Server mit lauter virtuellen Servern drauf oder deinen eigenen TeamSpeak Server irgendwo hinstellen. Dann würdest du natürlich eher irgendwas machen, wo normale Betriebssysteme drauf flutschig laufen. So was mit ordentlich...
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt deinen Blog hosten willst, dann nimmst du dir einen kleinen Server, machst da einen Linux drauf oder meinetwegen auch einen Windows Server und host dann deinen Blog darauf, nimmst dann eine Kiste, die hat irgendwie einen Netzwerkport und die geht auf einen Switch von deinem Hoster. Aber der Hoster zum Beispiel hat dann halt Router und Switches, die halt eigentlich nur darauf optimiert sind, Daten von A nach B zu schicken. Also es kommt auf Kabel 1 rein, geht auf Kabel 2 wieder raus. Und der sucht dann halt auch automatisch den günstigsten Weg zum nächsten.
Ich möchte es dann mal so versuchen zusammenzufassen, wie ich es jetzt verstanden habe, und das möglicherweise auch so versteht von Leuten, die da keine Ahnung haben. Ihr sagt genau das richtig. Also der Server zum Web-Posting ist quasi ein richtiger Computer, wie wir ihn von zu Hause kennen, ohne vielleicht das schöne Gehäuse, aber hat halt irgendwie so Prozessor, RAM, Festplatten und irgendwie so auch einen Netzwerkanschluss, wo halt der Internetwerk herausgeht.
Also die sind zollbreit, so zwei, drei Zentimeter hoch und gut durchlüftet und super laut, aber kein großer Unterschied zum Computer, den man auch zu Hause hat, außer dass sie leistungsfähiger sind.
Und die anderen Sachen, sozusagen um teilzunehmen an einem großen Netzwerkeverkehr, das ist quasi eine Ansammlung von Netzwerkkarten.
Genau, eine Netzwerkkarte in Gehäusen, wo dann ein spezielles Betriebssystem draufläuft, das nur auf Netzwerkdaten hin und her schieben optimiert wurde.
Alles klar, habe ich jetzt verstanden. Ihr hoffentlich auch, wenn nicht, ruft ihr an. 033 177 97 110. Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club und ein bisschen Musik von Freiheit hören wir jetzt. Und das ist einer der Songs, die vom Free Music Sampler 2012 mit aufgenommen worden sind. Sehr schöne Geschichte dahinter auch, die Musik, der Sampler ist gerade rausgekommen und die Leute streiten sich auch gerade mit der GEMA, ob man nämlich für Creative Commons Musik auch bezahlen soll. Das Gericht hat erstmal gesagt, ja, mal gucken, was da noch passiert. Wir hören jetzt erstmal ein Titel aus genau diesem Sampler. Tapete, kennt ihr vielleicht von Anzeint, da sind die häufiger schon gewesen. Jetzt sind sie auch auf dem Free Music Sampler Freedom and Free Beer mit dem Song von Freiheit nicht genug. Wir werden diesen Sampler noch ausführlicher vorstellen, den Trackback, aber erst nächste Woche, weil diese Woche ja Samstag kein Trackback ist, weil da die neuen Deutsch Poeten stattfinden. Jetzt sind wir im Chaos Radio Imble Moon mit Erdgeist und Kay. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Willkommen zurück.
Und wir sprechen heute über das Internet und wie es funktioniert, nicht technisch, sondern wer da so als Firma mit dran beteiligt ist, als Player. Wir haben schon gelernt, wie die letzte Meile aufgeteilt und verkauft wird. Wir haben gelernt, was das Datenpaket, wenn es aus eurer Wohnung raus ist und durch die letzte Meile durch dann macht. Nämlich, es steht in einem sogenannten Internet Exchange Center auf. Das heißt, alle Firmen, die in einem bestimmten lokalen Gebiet irgendwas mit Internet machen, stellen dort ihre Rechner rein und verteilen die Datenverkehrer untereinander und routen sie auch quasi nach draußen. Zum Beispiel in so einem Übersiegelkabel, was echt teuer ist. Und bevor wir, ich muss jetzt, ich bin hier die ganze Zeit schon ganz gierig drauf, dass wir über CDNs reden.
Noch eine Korrektur. Das sind nicht Internet Exchanges, sondern sind Rechenzentren oder Co-Locations, nennt man sie. Und dort drin stehen zum Beispiel neben den Hostern auch Internet Exchanges.
Das ist bis jetzt auch nicht klar geworden.
Also ein Internet Exchange ist eigentlich nichts anderes als einen Switch, wie in jeder Zuhause zum Verteilen vom Internet benutzt hinter dem WLAN Router. Nur, dass die Switches halt viel größer sind und viel mehr können. Aber im Grunde ist das nur ein Verteiler und alle können darüber sprechen. Und das ist auch nur ein Kasten in einem Schrank, in einem Haus, was eine Klima hat.
Jetzt würde ich glaube ich aber, bevor wir zum CDN kommen, tatsächlich noch mal über das Übersiegkabel sprechen wollen, weil das ja so tierisch teuer ist. Dass er den Datenverkehr, wie der Herr Erdgeist schon häufig angemerkt hat, jetzt so teuer macht, weil man da so viele Investitionen reingelegt, rein versenkt hat und die dann irgendwann wieder auszahlen. Kann einer von euch mal beschreiben, wie so ein Untersiegkabel eigentlich aussieht, was so, keine Ahnung, Europa und Amerika verbindet?
Ja, so ein Unterseekabel ist in der Regel, also die allerersten waren noch Kupferkabel, aber inzwischen sind das alles Glasfaserkabel. Das ist dann irgendwie ein riesig fettes Bündel mit mehreren hundert Glasfasern. Die werden dann wieder rüber einfach in einem dicken Mantel verlegt, der irgendwie mit Stahlgewebe ist, dass das nicht schnell kaputt geht, dass da auch mal ein Hai reinbeißen kann oder so.
Ah, Kabel.
Und dann gibt es da halt verschiedene Punkte. Normalerweise läuft das halt so an der Küste lang, das Kabel, und hat dann immer so Stichstellen rein ins Land und kann dann an verschiedenen Punkten abgegriffen werden oder Sachen dazugespeist werden können. Und dann gibt es da noch Repeater drin, weil man kann jetzt nicht das in der einen Seite in die Glasfaser reinleuchten und es kommt in Amerika raus, sondern man muss das mehr darüber mehrfach verstärken und deswegen läuft da auch noch Strom mit in dem Kabel, um diese Repeater zu betreiben, die dann alle paar hundert Kilometer stehen und das Signal verstärken.
Da gibt es auch eine Karte im Internet, da kann man sich mal so visualisieren, wie da diese Kabel um die Welt herum verlegt sind.
Genau, und zwar ist das cablemap.info, da seht ihr eine Weltkarte und ganz viele Linien und da seht ihr mal grob, wie viele Kabel da so verlegt sind und da steht auch, wenn man dann auf einen Strich draufklickt, wie viel Bandbreite darüber geht, es sind mehrere Terabits zum Beispiel.
Und jetzt haben wir in die Sendung angefangen, dass ihr gesagt habt, so ein Kabel wurde irgendwie beschädigt. Legen die dann einfach auf dem Meerboden da rum oder wie ist das?
Mehr oder weniger, ja. Also die Kabel werden halt einfach auf einem Schiff hinten transportiert und dann ins Wasser geworfen und dann sinken sie runter in der Regel und liegen dann halt da.
Also Küstner werden sie dann schon noch, teilweise werden da noch Graben gebuddelt, dann werden die da reingelassen, dann werden sie wieder zugebuddelt und dann ist wie genau an Land, dass du dann aufpassen musst, dass irgendwie verbuddelt, heißt ja nicht verbuddelt, wenn da so ein großes Schiff vorbeikommt, da sein Anker einfach unter unter Wasser dann auf den Grund lässt und dann wieder losfährt, vergisst den Anker hochzunehmen.
Das passiert mehrfach im Jahr, dass irgendwer irgendwie ein Kabel beschädigt und ja, dann ist das Kabel durch oder beschädigt, dann muss halt ein Schiff wieder rauskommen, das fährt dann dahin, sucht die kaputte Stelle, sucht das Kabel, holt das ans, zieht das dann hoch und guckt sich an und repariert es.
Das sind irgendwie einige der kompliziertesten internationalen Verträge, die da so geschlossen werden können, sind so überhaupt Kabel, die man durchs Meer zieht, weil das ja nicht nur jetzt Netzwerkkabel, die da so Glasfarbepfaser zwischen den Kontinenten, sondern auch Stromkabel, so aus deinen Offshore, neu gebauten Offshore-Windkraftwerken zum Beispiel. Und da ist ja dann plötzlich, wenn du mehrere Kabel liegst, die sich auch noch kreuzen, dann ist ja immer eins oben. Und wenn einer seins flicken möchte, dann ist plötzlich das andere oben. Und wenn es irgendwie mal kaputt gegangen ist, dann sieht man die hoch, knurrt man sie wieder zusammen und lässt sie wieder runter. Und dann plötzlich musst du die Verträge wieder ändern, weil die Wartung von so Kabeln, die da so untereinander liegen, schon echt komplex ist.
Und deswegen ist es auch toll, dieses Kabel zu benutzen. Und das heißt ja sagen, wenn ich jetzt anfange, auf meinem Rechner eine Webseite zu klicken, sagen wir mal.
Was du so tust, wenn du hochauflösende Vorplantungsdokumenten.
Oder du klickst zum Beispiel bei deinem Rechner auf Update und er zieht sich mal die aktuellen Software Sachen runter.
Von linux.com irgendwo aus US Amerika.
Genau, dann sagen, ich würde jetzt mal kurz sagen, beschreiben wollen, ihr sagt, ob ich was falsch gemacht habe, von dem, was ich bis jetzt ziemlich gelernt habe. Und da würde man ja denken, so okay, also ich sitze irgendwo in Berlin. In Berlin geht das Ding durch die Wand, geht dann halt in so eine Co-Location-Server-Ding, wo auch ein Internet Exchange steht, der guckt sich das Paket an, stellt fest, ja, haben wir leider keinen hier, der irgendwie jetzt so Dings ist, das sitzt in Amerika. Schickt dann also das Paket raus, das geht dann über weitere so Internet Exchanges, bisschen dieses Tiefseekabel, was total teuer ist und lang. Wieso nicht?
Das Internet Exchange ist wirklich nur so ein Austauschpunkt, das kann man so vergleichen mit irgendwie einem schwarzen Brett, wo jeder dran schreibt, was er hat und wie man da hinkommt. Davor gibt es dann noch mal Provider, die schließen sich. Also du gehst dann hin und gibst deine Daten, einen Provider und der kümmert sich dann darum, dass es zum Beispiel zu dem Internet Exchange geht oder er transportiert das durch sein eigenes Unterseekabel nach Amerika, weil er dort mit jemand verbunden ist, der den Content hat. Und die Internet Exchanges sind dann nur so ein neutraler Knotenpunkt, die eine Plattform bieten zum Austausch. Und da gehen dann die Provider hin, mieten sich den Port drauf und tauschen dann die Daten mit anderen Providern aus.
Und wieso kommt da mein Paket nicht vorbei?
Es muss nicht vorbeikommen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt...
Wir sind jetzt gerade beim Beispiel, mein Paket will nach Amerika.
Genau. Und nach Amerika hast du jetzt keinen an deinem... Also du bist jetzt zum Beispiel ein kleiner Provider hier in Berlin, bist an einem Internet Exchange in Berlin angeschlossen. Und da hast du jetzt zum Beispiel nicht eine Firma aus Amerika, weil das halt nur ein sehr kleiner Kreis ist, der da angeschlossen ist. Also nur ein Bruchteil vom Internet. Aber du hast dann halt weitere Upstreams. Zum Beispiel, ja, Deutsche Telekom, Global Crossing oder Telia. Und denen gibst du dann die Daten. Und die haben wiederum so ein großes Netz, das um die ganze Welt reicht. Und die transportieren das dann für dich weiter.
Aber das ist doch, sagen wir, trotzdem auf diesem Internet Exchange ausgetauscht worden, oder nicht?
Nee. Also du kannst entweder auswählen, es geht über einen Internet Exchange. Oder du gibst es einem Uplink-Provider, so genannt er.
Das wird jetzt zu kompliziert. Wir können ja einfach mal versuchen, zu sagen, da ist irgendwie noch mehr, da ist so tief, wenn man nicht reinleuchtet, das wird dann ganz schnell ziemlich verwoben. Man kann ja wieder einfach halber einfach mal sagen, dass es so ungefähr auch funktioniert, dass man die Preise, die jetzt die Durchleitung bei diesen Upstream-Providern, dass man die vergleicht mit dem, was man vielleicht bei den lokalen Zixen dort bezahlen würde und sich dann den günstigsten Anbieter raussucht und am Ende sich nicht weiter darum kümmert, wo das Paket wirklich landet, sondern einfach sagt, ich hab hier ein Internetpaket und ich würde jetzt gerne das über den billigsten Anbieter verschicken und dann gibt's dann Algorithmen, die einem das ausrechnen, was da grad der optimale Weg ist. Aber auch am Ende ist natürlich dann der Preis, den das nimmt, ist eine der Metriken. Du willst ja deinen Kunden auch nicht unbedingt einen Paket nach dem günstigsten Preis nur zumuten. Wenn das dann einfach so durch die billigsten Anbieter kommt, aber dann da so mehrere Sekunden Latenz plötzlich hat, ist es wie eine schlechte Metrik, einfach nur den Preis daherzunehmen, sondern du misst da mal alles Mögliche auf und hast dann am Ende rausgefunden, dass dein Kunde sehr unzufrieden ist, wenn er sich jetzt die Tierdokumentation dort mit einer Bandbreite von nur 10 Kilobit pro Sekunde nach Hause ziehen kann. Also will er wahrscheinlich dort mal eine dicke Bandbreite haben und ist wahrscheinlich auch bereit, dafür dann Geld zu bezahlen für andere Dinge. Will er halt dann vielleicht nicht so schnell ist oder vielleicht, wie geht das auch mit größer Latenz noch in Ordnung?
Aber das ist dann eine Mischkalkulation, die der Provider wieder macht. Weil sagen, ich als Kunde bezahle immer nur einen Preis.
Du kannst auch gar nicht entscheiden.
Als Kunde würde es dann vielleicht im Zweifel eher weggehen, wenn irgendwie bei mir zu Hause geht Skype langsam. Wenn bei der Telekom ging es aber voll schnell, dann gehe ich halt woanders hin. Also man kann natürlich seinem Kunden irgendwie so Dinge zumuten, bis das Kamell platzt.
Ja genau, aber ich wollte gerade sagen, das entscheidet der Provider, das berechnet ihm nicht einzeln, sondern zu sagen, ich bezahle meine 20 Euro und der Provider entscheidet dann so, okay, die Leute, die da wohnen, die gucken alle viele hochauflösende Fortplantungsdokumentationen, aber skypen wenig, deswegen sozusagen können wir das so. Und wenn er sich dann falsch entscheidet, dann sagt der Kunde so, ich geh mal weg. Okay, aber ich als Kunde sehe das nicht, wie er sich entschieden hat. Merkt das höchstens, wenn er sich falsch entschieden hat.
Nun hast du aber das Problem, dass viele von den Informationen, die so Leute sich besorgen wollen, auch identisch sind. Also wenn plötzlich viele Leute in der Welt gleichzeitig sich die neue Version des Betriebssystems herunterladen möchten, dann hast du sowohl als Provider, der den Kunden das jetzt zukommen lassen möchte, als auch derjenige, der es anbietet, hast du so ein Problem. Da gibt es so Möglichkeiten, das zu lösen. BitTorrent zum Beispiel ist aber so für eine garantierte Qualität, die du deinen Kunden liefern möchtest, jetzt nicht so immer die optimale Wahl. Und dann gibt es andere Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel ein...
Also ein CDN ist eine Firma meistens, die ich halt... Halt.
Was heißt CDN?
Stimmt. Das heißt Content Delivery Network. Also die verteilen sozusagen den Inhalt. Und wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel eine Firma hingeht, die jetzt ein Update rausbringt für ihr Betriebssystem, das ist dann irgendwie einen Gigabyte groß. Und die wollen natürlich, dass alle das richtig schnell bekommen. Und die haben jetzt aber nur ihre Server in Amerika, in ihrer Zentrale stehen. Und die übergeben dann dieses Paket mit dem neuen Betriebssystem drinne, so im CDN, die haben in der ganzen Welt verteilt kleine Inseln. In Rechenzentren haben sie dann irgendwie zehn Racks, randvoll mit Server, mit viel Platten und ganz schnell angebunden. Und haben davon in jeder Stadt einstehen. Oder sogar in manchen Providern drinne. Also zum Beispiel bei deinem DSL Provider steht dann auch so mehrere Schränke von diesem Content Delivery Network. Und die kümmern sich darum, dass der Content dann auf allen diesen Servern ist und somit ganz, ganz nah beim Kunden.
So, was der Kunde dann sieht ist, er macht eine Anfrage im DNS, also bei Name Server und fragt, sag mal, wo steht eigentlich updates.microsoft.com? Und dann guckt dein Name Server, der bei deinem Provider eingetragen ist, guckt nach und sagt, ja gut, jetzt könnte ich dir sagen, der ist in Amerika, will ich aber grad nicht, sondern updates.microsoft.com steht hier. Bei mir lokal, wie mit dieser IP-Adresse kannst du runterladen. Und man würde sich dann einfach zu einem Rechner dieser Content Delivery Networks hinconnecten und würde dann am Ende über die Signatur rausfinden müssen, das ist wirklich korrekt, das ist wirklich Microsoft und würde dann anfangen statt über das teure Überseekabel, dieses Update runterzuladen, dann einfach von dem Server, den da dieser CDN bei deinem Provider hingestellt hat, direkt anfangen runterzuladen.
Das kann man auch beobachten, wenn man bei Videos, das fällt das glaube ich oft an, wenn man so kleine Firewall-Programme auf seinem Rechner laufen hat, dann fragt das manchmal, obwohl man sich jetzt zu hochauflösende fortpflanzungsdokumentation.de verbunden hat, nach so einer ganz kruden Nummer, so ehe entlange Namen stehen, möglicherweise so was wie Akamai drin oder sowas. Das ist dann so ein Content Delivery Network Server.
Ja, es gibt einfach zwei große gerade und Akamai ist einer der ersten, die da drauf gekommen sind. Die haben irgendwann, war glaube ich ein Universitätsprojekt und dann hat Apple noch ganz früh darin investiert, die da Webobjekts sich ausgedacht haben und dort jetzt für ihre ersten Updates und ich glaube ihre ersten Versuche mit dem iTunes Music Store wollten sie selber machen, sondern wollten sie einkaufen und haben sie an Akamai investiert. Und war auch irgendwie das erste Geld, was dann damals Apple auch wieder verdient hatte, nachdem es ihnen schlecht ging, glaube ich. Und die sind irgendwie so einer der ersten großen Spieler und die hatten irgendwie dann ziemlich schlaue Algorithmen, um rauszufinden, was denn jetzt gerade heiße Files sind. Also Files, die gerade ganz viel von Leuten aus einer Region angefragt worden sind, weil du hast natürlich wieder eine andere Metrik. Du kannst ja nicht das gesamte Angebot deines Kunden jetzt überall spiegeln, was gar nicht angefragt wird. Sondern musst irgendwie schon schauen, was sind gerade, wenn in Deutschland so die Leute vom Update Server nur die deutsche Version des Betriebssystems wollen, dann kann man natürlich da schon vorbauen und sich auf der Seite des Anbieters dafür darum kümmern, dass irgendwie jetzt nur das deutsche Sprachpaket damit bei ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite will man das eigentlich auch Algorithmen machen lassen. Wenn du siehst, dass dasselbe Pfeil aus der Region Deutschland in ein paar Millionenfach angefragt ist, dann kriegt das Content-Delivery-Network das mit und holt sich das dann einmal aus US-Amerika und sorgt dann dafür, dass wenn alle anderen dasselbe Pfeil haben wollen, dass das dann eher lokal ausgeliefert wird.
Das hört sich ja sozusagen nach einer recht menschenfreundlichen, ideellen Vorgehensweise an, dass das Content-Delivery-Network sagt, hey, ihr wollt alle diese Datei haben, kein Problem, ich hol sie euch und leg sie bei uns drauf. Aber da muss doch irgendjemand dafür bezahlen. Wer?
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder sehr unterschiedlich. Also eigentlich zahlt dann am Ende der, der sagt, ich hab hier meine Datei, die muss verteilt werden. Und dann bezahlt er dafür, dass die zum Beispiel überall in bestimmter Geschwindigkeit verfügbar ist.
Ach so, das läuft dann sozusagen nicht so, dass er sagt, ich möchte, dass diese Datei gerade verteilt wird. Und dann wird die sozusagen nach seinem Willen auf bestimmte Server dieses CDNs hochgeladen, sondern er sagt das und dass die CDN-Firma hat einen Algorithmus, der ausrechnet, wo diese Dateien verteilt werden müssen.
Genau, also man sagt dann zum Beispiel, was für eine Art ist, wenn das jetzt zum Beispiel für die Fußballwende oder Olympiade ist, dann wird gesagt, das ist ein Livestream. Und der kann dann zum Beispiel, weil dann gerade Deutschland spielt, kann sein, dass jetzt ganz viel in Deutschland dafür gebraucht wird, aber wenig Kapazität woanders. Und dann kümmert sich, also das CDN ist dann, er kennt das und kümmert sich darum, dass in Deutschland dafür genügend Kapazitäten vorhanden sind.
Aber der sozusagen der Auftraggeger sagt tatsächlich nur, ich habe hier diesen Inhalt und ich möchte, dass der überall auf der Welt oder sozusagen, er kann noch das Gebiet anschränken wahrscheinlich.
Genau, er sagt dann die Zielgruppe ist zum Beispiel in Europa und das möchten wir da, dass das zu dieser Uhrzeit live geht auf allen Knoten und alle sollen das schnell runterladen können.
Das ist ja erstmal eine sehr gute Einrichtung, könnte man sagen, aber hat das auch einen Nachteil, also was ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen kann, dass die sich wirtschaftlich in einer sehr guten Position irgendwann befinden. Also wenn er gerade auch sagt, es gibt noch irgendwie so zwei große Player in dem Feld, wenn die dann irgendwie sagen, ja nö, lass mal die Preise erhöhen, dann haben ja eigentlich die Firmen schlechte Karten, oder?
Du hast dann ja auch nur ein bestimmtes Budget dafür. Also wir haben ja am Anfang die Frage gestellt, wer bezahlt eigentlich das Internet? Und was wir gerade rausgefunden haben, sind Leute, die da wirklich ihr Geld reintun können. Sind auf der einen Seite die Leute, die zu Hause ihr DSL haben wollen. Wir haben auch gesehen, dass in den ganzen Mischkalkulationen, da immer nur ziemlich wenig Luft drin ist, da kannst du dich beliebig an einer Preisschraube drehen und dann gehen die Preise auch herunter. Und die anderen Leute sind die, die irgendwo Server mieten. Und das machen sie ja meistens auch nicht, um dann wie nur Server rumstehen zu haben, sondern die wollen dann wie Geschäfte betreiben oder hoffen da am Ende auch wieder, ein Business mit dem Internet irgendwie zu machen oder das Geld reinzubekommen. Und da kannst du auch nicht beliebig an der Stellschraube hochdrehen, weil dann sich das auch nicht mehr lohnen würde, weil der Empfänger auf der anderen Seite dem Internet ja auch nicht beliebig Lust hat, für die Produkte dann mehr Geld noch drauf zu bezahlen. Also trotzdem ist das Geld, was erstmal drin ist, wird jetzt natürlich auch mit harten Bandagen verteilt. Also, ich weiß nicht, es gibt einige... Na ja, es gab da so Hin- und Heereffekte, dass zum Beispiel gab es vor zwei Jahren so eine Geschichte in Großbritannien, wo die DSL-Provider plötzlich der Meinung waren, die BBC macht aber mit ihren ganzen HD-Dokumentationen, die sich alle Leute jetzt runterladen, also wirkliche Tierdokumentation, machen sie so viel Traffic bei unseren Kunden und die wollen uns alle runterladen, jetzt wollen wir mal damit, wie die BBC noch ordentlich durchleiten, von der BBC Geld dafür sehen. Ja, und die BBC hat sich hingestellt, brrr, nee. Und dann war das dann auch ziemlich schnell gegessen. Dann war dieser Blöff dann auch ziemlich schnell aufgerufen. Und auf der anderen Seite sieht es jetzt so aus, dass eher Leute, die Content zur Verfügung stellen, in sich einer starken Verhandlungsposition fühlen und meinen, ja, wir sind Google, wir haben irgendwie diesen YouTube-Service und eure Kunden wollen bestimmt ganz schnell YouTube gucken können und die werden sich bestimmt auch beschweren, wenn es nicht sehr schnell durchgeht. Deswegen sind unsere Peering-Konditionen jetzt so und so.
Da kann man so zum Beispiel das Beispiel nehmen, bei diesem Provider, wenn Sie zwei Provider verknüpfen, zum Beispiel jetzt, wenn Kabel Deutschland mit Google jetzt zusammen sich verknüpft, damit die Daten schön schnell fließen. Das gibt es auch jetzt in, also normalerweise macht man das halt, weil es auf Gegenseitigkeit beruht. Der Content ist dann froh, dass er schnell beim Nutzer ist. Der Nutzer ist froh, dass er schnell beim Content ist und es wenig kostet. Aber zum Beispiel Deutsche Telekom, wenn man sich mit denen zusammenschalten will und entweder man ist einer von den richtig, richtig großen, dann sagt die Telekom, okay, wir sehen dann, wir sehen, dass es Geld kosten würde, aber wir machen jetzt das beide auf Gegenseitigkeit und berechnen nichts dafür. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel einer, der nicht der riesig großen in Deutschland ist, dann sagen die halt ganz einfach, hey, wenn du schnell bei unseren Kunden sein willst, dann bezahl doch dafür. Und genauso...
Das ist dann nicht mehr Netzneutralität, oder? Das ist jetzt die Frage, die mir jetzt so sein die ganze Zeit auf der Zunge liegt. Also diese Idee ist ja, dass alle gleich Inhalt immer gleich schnell sind, aber schon diese CDNs sind dann eigentlich eine Verletzung, dieses Prinzip.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, was die Telekom macht, das nennt sich einfach in der Branche paid peering, also bezahlte Zusammenkunft dann einfach.
Bisschen wir nach Prostitution an, ich kann mich grad nicht...
Ja, zum Beispiel von einem anderen großen CDN, da gibt's also die Regel so, wir schließen uns nicht mit kleinen Providern zusammen, außer sie tauschen irgendwie so und so 4 Gigabit mit uns aus. Oder sie zahlen Geld pro für die ausgetauschten Daten.
Das heißt, das ist schon auch so ein Markt, wo es halt nicht so einfach ist, mal zu sagen, okay, ich mach jetzt hier einfach noch meinen eigenen Provider. Weil von der technischen Seite klang das ja die ganze Zeit so wie, natürlich kannst du das machen und dir auch einen eigenen Server in so einen Call Location Space, also so ein Server-Haus reinstellen, aber wirtschaftlich oder sozusagen von der Geschwindigkeit her ist es nicht so einfach, weil die großen Player da gut zusammenhalten.
Ja, also es beruht halt sehr auf den anderen darin, dem ganzen Spiel und man erreicht auch als Kleiner relativ gut die anderen und wenn man halt zu einem bestimmten hin will, der jetzt einer der Großen ist, dann kann man ja sich zum Beispiel bei einem anderen Großen einkaufen und dann zum Beispiel von denen sagen, ich will von euch jetzt den Traffic haben, der zur deutschen Telekom fließt.
Okay, also muss man dann über Mittelsmann gehen. Jetzt haben wir diese CDNs endlich mal. Das wurde ja aber auch Zeit. Jetzt sind ja gleich schon wieder Nachrichten. Was bleibt uns denn noch, was wir in der letzten halben Stunde alles nicht mehr schaffen?
Wir sind eigentlich schon unsere Choreografie doch genau im Zeitplan geblieben. Du hast ja jetzt das Zettel doch da rumliegen, oder?
Jetzt hör mal auf mich so hinzustellen, als wäre ich nicht vorbereitet, was zwar stimmt, aber jetzt nicht an dieser Stelle immer erwähnt werden muss. Erdgeist! Okay, als Werbezeichen noch RIP. Könnt ihr schon kurz mal anteasern, was das ist?
Na, die vergeben so die Zahlen, also die Nummern, unter denen Rechner erreichbar ist im Internet.
Ach, wir können das aber generischer fassen. Im Laufe der Zeit hast du irgendwie wie im Wilden Westen da alle haben wie wild ihre Eisenbahnlinien durch die Gegend verlegt. Ein paar Leute bauen Straßen, ein paar Leute erschießen Indianer und irgendwann hast du doch nochmal eine Regulierung, die notwendig ist, um dort wieder ein bisschen Ordnung in diesen Wilden Westen dort rein zu schaffen. Irgendwann sind die IP-Adressen alle irgendwann, will man auch glaube ich dafür sorgen, dass es so ein paar grundsätzliche Spielregeln der Leute untereinander gibt, die dann von doch irgendwie eigentlich noch recht freundlich gesinnten Engineers dann so im halbwegs im Konsens da besprochen werden. Und diese Institutionen, die das regulieren, die wollen wir jetzt in der letzten halben Stunde ansprechen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Das Line-up ist komplett. Die Sonne ist bestellt. Und die geheimen Geheimgäste sind auch noch geheim. Eigentlich nur noch ihr, falls ihr noch kein Ticket habt.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das Fritz Open Air Festival. Mit TS. Ullmann, The Koleckis und Tim Bensko. Mit Timo Hauer, Vierkantretlager und Max Herren. Und dazu ein paar ziemlich geheime Geheimgäste.
Kommen am Samstag live von Open Air. In IFA Sommergarten auf dem Messegelände Berlin. Und auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten auch bei Fritz im Netz.
Oder ihr gewinnt sie bei uns. Einfach gut, Fritz Hör.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das Fritz Open Air Festival.
Moderiert.
Auf der Bühne.
Um kurz nach halb 12.
Nachrichten.
Mit Martin Schneider.
Die Flugbegleiter der Lufthansa beginnen morgen ihren Streik in Frankfurt am Main. Das hat die Gewerkschaft UFO am späten Abend mitgeteilt. Der erste Ausstand des Kabinenpersonals in der Geschichte der Lufthansa soll demnach um 5 Uhr morgens beginnen und bis 13 Uhr dauern. Fluggäste müssen sich auf erhebliche Behinderungen und Flugausfälle einrichten. Wann der neue Hauptstadtflughafen tatsächlich eröffnet wird, soll erst nach der nächsten Aufsitzrat sich Sitzung der Flughafengesellschaft bekanntgegeben werden. Berlins regierender Bürgermeister Woverheit sagte dem RBB, dem neuen Technikchef Amann müsse die Zeit bis zum 14. September gegeben werden, um die Unterlagen intensiv zu prüfen. Die Flughafeneröffnung ist nach zwei gescheiterten Terminen für den 17. März 2013 vorgesehen. Fachleute bezweifeln jedoch, dass dieser Termin gehalten werden kann. Das Drama Barbara geht als deutscher Beitrag in den Wettbewerb um den Oscar 2013. Es geht um den Preis für den besten nicht englischsprachigen Film. Eine Fachjury in München hat sich für das Drama über eine ostdeutsche Ärztin entschieden. Schon bei der Berlinale 2012 bekam der Film von Regisseur Christian Petzold den silbernen Bären für die beste Regie. Der Iran hat nach Angaben der internationalen Atomenergieorganisation eine seiner Urananreicherungsanlagen beträchtlich erweitert. Die Zahl der Zentrifugen in dem unterirdischen Komplex sei seit Mai auf 2000 verdoppelt worden, heißt es in dem neuesten Bericht der Behörde. Der Westen wirft Teheran vor, nach Atomwaffen zu streben. Die iranische Regierung weist dies zurück und pocht auf ihr Recht zur friedlichen Nutzung der Atomenergie.
Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Buch haben wir 18 Grad, in Wannsee messen wir 20 Grad, in Cottbus sind es bloß noch 17, Potsdam, Frankfurt, Mittenberg in Europin, Angermünde 18 Grad. Bis zum Morgen ziehen jede Menge dichte Wolken samt Regen durch, teilweise kann es auch gewittern, und die Temperaturen gehen auch bis auf 13 Grad runter. Der Freitag wird dann stark bewölkt, und es gibt jede Menge Regen, maximal 12 Grad, nee, 20 sind immerhin drin. Am Wochenende wird es dann trotz Regenschauern wieder etwas freundlicher. Die Straßen sind scheinbar frei, wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de fritz.de Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Heute Chaosradio mit Erdgeist und Kay, die ich das Internet erkläre, genauer wer darin Geld für was nimmt und bezahlen muss. Und auf Wunsch eines einzelnen Herrn, der heute hier anwesend ist, gibt es jetzt an dieser Stelle auch noch Musik und zwar einen Totentanz. Es ist ja ein nicht endwollendes Klischee, dass gerade Mitglieder des Chaos Computer Clubs nur Bitmusik hören. Ich habe in meiner langen Zeit hier als Chaos-Radio-Moderator gelernt, dass das Gegenteil der Fall ist. Dass gerade solche Musik, wie wir gerade hier gehört haben, da sehr beliebt ist. Das war der Toten Dance von Caldron. Das ist Musik vom Free Music Sampler diesen Jahres, den Titel Freedom and Free Beer trägt, so nicht man sie auch runterladen kann. Link gibt es nach der Sendung im Blog zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. Da seid ihr nämlich im Chaos Radio zu Gastin Erdgeist und Kay. Hallo und willkommen zurück zur letzten, na ja, fast halben Stunde. Genau, wir sprechen gleich noch über das Thema, wer nämlich im Internet was und wie bezahlt und bezahlen kann. Vorher noch eine kleine News, die wir verbreiten wollen.
Es handelt sich um eine große Java-Lücke. Und ich persönlich fand das sehr ulkig, weil ein Kumpel mich vor drei Tagen darauf hingewiesen hat, dass ein ehemaliger Sun-Ingenieur, also diese Firma, die ziemlich coole Erfindungen wie zum Beispiel das ZFS und D-Trace gebaut hat, was eher Hacker interessiert, aber die haben auch Java erfunden. Und irgendwann ist diese Firma Sun, weil wenn Engineers so eine Firma versuchen, selber zu steuern, sind die auch in ein bisschen finanziell harte Zeiten gekommen und wurden dann von einer der echt bösen Firmen aufgekauft namens Oracle. Und Oracle hat als Ziel nicht so etwas wie Enabling People zu helfen, sondern einfach Geld verdienen und das zeigt sich jetzt, dass die da nicht so richtig mit der Community umgehen können, weil sie haben ihr Java so ein bisschen verrotten lassen und schon vor einem halben Jahr haben ein paar Sicherheitsforscher gesagt, ihr habt ein echtes Problem, euer Sandboxing im Browser funktioniert nicht, man kann irgendwie ziemlich einfach dem... Das heißt, dass der Browser sorgt natürlich dafür, dass irgendwas, was in deiner Webseite ausgeführt wird, nicht an deine privaten Familienfotos darf. Und sowas heißt Sandboxing, also man sperrt also ein Prozess an eine kleine Sandbox ein, in so einen Wuddelkasten, in dem darf es machen, was es möchte, aber an die Familienfotos darf es nicht ran. Und es gibt jetzt einen ganz einfachen Weg, sich so diese Sandkasten-Umgebung einfach kaputt zu spielen, außer aus diesem Java heraus und zu sagen, ich will aber doch und ich bin nämlich gar nicht aus dem Internet, sondern ich lag vorher schon auf der Festplatte, deswegen darf ich alles. Und das wurde der Firma Oracle schon vor einem halben Jahr mitgeteilt und die haben einfach Müscht gemacht. Und dazwischen sieht es so aus, dass wenn du mit deinem Browser auf irgendeiner Webseite vorbeikommst, wo ein Java-Ablett noch drin ist und du es nicht irgendwann schon mal ausgeschaltet hast, also wenn du Java in deinem Browser nicht irgendwie schon mal ausgeschaltet hast, hast du gerade ein Problem. So, egal auf welchen Betriebssystem, gerade mit welchem Browser, wenn du Java anhast, dann hast du ein Problem, dein Rechner ist sozusagen dann schon prinzipiell in fremder Hand. Und genau, das ging jetzt so in den letzten Tagen durch die Presse und es hat für mich dann auch wieder so den Eindruck bestätigt, dass einfach solche wichtige Kerninfrastruktur, die jetzt auch Java darstellt, weil es einfach in allen Browsern eingebaut ist, dann nicht in die Firma, in die Hände von so einer raffgierigen Firma wie Oracle gehört.
Man muss ja noch dazusagen, die Sicherheitslücke, das ist ja nicht so einfach. Also man kann bei vielen Browsern sagen, hier bitte kein Java mehr benutzen, außer beim Internet Explorer. Das hatten wir heute sogar in Nachrichten, dass es halt genau nicht geht. Hatten wir das in Nachrichten? Egal. Es war auf jeden Fall groß genug. Es gibt wohl eine Anleitung für den Internet Explorer, die ist aber so kompliziert, dass da wohl die normalen Leute nicht so richtig durchsteigen.
Da könnte man einfach gleich die Linux CD reinschieben, das ist glaube ich ein bisschen weniger kompliziert. Es gibt ja auch inzwischen Distributionen, die einfach für den Großteil der Anwender schon so window-isch aussehen, dass man da sich einfach kaum noch Ärger einhandelt. Also besser als Windows 98 ist es allemal.
Okay. Jetzt aber zurück zum Internet, wo wir heute schon gelernt haben, wie die letzte Meile gebaut und bezahlt wird, wie das Datenpaket von der letzten Meile in das erste Rechenzentrum und von dort auch immer weiterkommt und wie Inhalte, die sehr, sehr, sehr beliebt sind, verteilt werden, nämlich über sogenannte CDNs, Content Delivery Networks, wo halt Leute, Rechner in sozusagen lokalen Serverzentren stehen haben und sagen, okay, wenn der Inhalt total beliebt ist, bewerft ihr uns mit Geld, dann tun wir das dahin und dann ist das schneller bei euren Kunden. Das letzte, was wir im Internet noch klären wollen, ist das sogenannte RIPE. Wofür steht das eigentlich und was macht das?
Das RIPE ist eigentlich eine Organisation, die besteht eigentlich aus, grob gesagt, zwei Teilen. Einmal der Organisation, die das ausführt, was der andere Teil, die Community, sagt.
Und worum kümmern die sich, wenn es ums Internet geht?
Die kümmern sich drum um die Verteilung der IP-Adressen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel google.de eingibt, dann ist das in Wirklichkeit eine Adresse hinten, die heißt 1.2.3.4 als Beispiel. Ist jetzt nicht die echte. Und damit Google die benutzen darf, muss das halt zugeteilt werden. Und das passiert in Europa von der RIPE. Also weltweit gibt es da die IANA, die verwaltet diese gesamten Internetnummern und verteilt das dann an regionale Internet-Registrars. Und in Europa ist das das RIPE bzw. das RIPE NCC. Und da schreibt man zum Beispiel als ISP hin eine Mail. Man ist jetzt Member geworden und will jetzt gerne IP-Adressen haben. Man braucht so und so viele für die und die Sachen und dann bekommt man die zugeteilt.
Und das, weil es ja heute um Geld geht, kostet genau wie viel?
Das ist Unterschied. Also je nachdem, wie viele IP-Adressen man hat, wird man da eingestuft von extra small bis extra large. Und das kostet glaube ich im schlimmsten Fall irgendwie 10.000 Euro mehr.
Also nicht wirklich viel Geld.
Ab 150 war doch irgendwie, oder?
Also es kostet Geld, aber es ist im Rahmen dessen, wie viel man dann nimmt, eigentlich erträglich. Also wenn ich jetzt sagen, meinen eigenen Provider aufmachen will, ist das Bezahlen der IP-Adresse jetzt nicht der größte Posten.
Üblicherweise, wenn du deinen eigenen Provider aufmachen möchtest, kommt es wieder darauf an, ob du schon aus dem Netzblock, wo du deinen Rechner da reinstellst, weil die kaufen sich die ja dann so in größeren Paletten als du, immer so in Blöcken, die dadurch auch so zweier potenzen. Und dann sagst du dann du, ich brauch davon sowas wie, hab da jetzt ein paar Kunden und brauch da jetzt so, ab 4000 Adressen oder vielleicht irgendwie ab 2048 Adressen, so in der Größenordnung.
Ja oder zum Beispiel, ich hab pro Tag im Schnitt so und so viele Neukunden und ich brauch genug Adressen für den nächsten Monat. Und ich hab grad nochmal nachgeschaut, selbst wenn man da richtig viele Adressen hat und als extra large gewährt wird, was irgendwie nur 10, 15 Provider in Deutschland sind, sind das nur 5000 Euro im Jahr. Also es sind bei den Beträgen, die man da spielt, um so und so viele IP-Adressen zu verwalten, ist das halt irgendwie Portokasse.
Mhm, allein der Strom schon für die ganzen Server, die du da reinschieben musst da. Also wir hatten ja vorhin, glaubt den, deine Frage, so ein bisschen elegant übergangen, wo du meintest, was es denn so kostet, so ein Rechenzentrum zu betreiben, aber das kommt irgendwie auf die B-Wag an und das kommt auf die...
Na macht ihr selber denn sowas?
Also wir betreiben kein Rechenzentrum, na ja doch. Also wir haben im Berliner Club im Keller einen Raum, der war früher mal ein Rechenzentrum. Da standen mehr Racks drinnen, eine Klimaanlage und so weiter. Aber inzwischen ist das auch alles, weil sich das nicht mehr rentiert, das selbst zu betreiben. Ist das inzwischen nur noch irgendwie ein Rack mit zwei, drei Servern drin und das war's. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel in einem Rechenzentrum einen Rack angemietet und dort legen wir unser eigenes Internet hin und verwalten das. Und da haben wir auch die eigenen Server drin stehen. Und da ziehen wir in dem Fall von dem Rechenzentrum, beziehen wir nur den Strom und die Standfläche für das Rack. Und ich glaube, da sind wir inzwischen bei so 26, 28 Cent die Kilowattstunde oder 30 sogar.
Okay, aber da hat ja keiner Hausnummer zu sagen, was das im Monat kostet insgesamt. Das finde ich halt immer das Spannende bei diesen Geschichten, weil letztlich die Frage, die nicht steht immer ist, auch kann ich das selber machen? Und dann scheint ja vor allem eine Kostenfrage zu sein.
Ich kann dir sagen, ich habe da so bei einem Provider in Dürrenberg, glaube ich, steht hier, habe ich mir einen Server angemietet und da bezahle ich da so, das heißt irgendwie auch noch der Traffic mit dabei. Aber so Stromkosten haben wir gesagt, das ist wie so knapp unter 30 Euro im Monat.
Ja, also du zahlst so 20 Euro an Strom im Monat für einen leistungsstarken Server, wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie einen Strom sparen, also in den Stromkosten ist halt meist die Kühlung drin, weil so irgendwie Hälfte, zwei Drittel, die du an Strom in den Server reinschiebst, kommen als Wärme wieder raus.
Hey, super. Aber zurück zum RIPE das kümmert sich also um die IP-Adressenvergabe und ihr habt gerade gesagt, das ist ein Verein mehr oder weniger und besteht aus zwei Teilen. Der eine, der Dinge beschließt, der andere, der es dann umsetzen muss. Wer ist in diesem Verein drin? Also bei den Rechenzentren haben wir gelernt, da tun sich einfach sozusagen die Leute zusammen, die in der Gegend da mehr oder weniger großes Interesse an so Technik haben. Wer ist das RIP?
Also im RIPE das ist die Community, das sind in Europa ISPs. Und zwar, wenn man halt ISP ist und dann die Größe erreicht, wo man eigene IP-Adressen haben will und auch beantragen möchte, dann wird man so genannte Loan, das steht für Local Internet Registrar. Das ist dann nochmal eine Unterart von dem Regional Internet Registrar wie die RIPE. Und da mit dem Mitglied werden, kauft man sich das Recht, die Adressen zu beantragen und man darf abstimmen. Dann in der RIPE betreibt man halt mehrere Mailing-Listen über die verschiedensten Themen, unter anderem zum Beispiel auch, wie diese Adressen vergeben werden. Dort wird dann über das Jahr in bestimmten Prozessen irgendwie halt entschieden, dass da jetzt ein Proposal, also ein Vorschlag für Regeln gemacht wird, über den dann zweimal im Jahr auf so einem Meeting abgestimmt wird. Also wenn da dann durchdiskutiert wurde, es keine Widersprüche gab und so weiter und so weiter, kommt es dann, wo es bei so einem General Meeting nennt sich das, also da treffen sich dann die ganzen Leute auf so einem Meeting und stimmen dann darüber ab, einen Tag lang, ob das angenommen wird. Und wenn es tatsächlich angenommen wird, wird dann dieses Regelwerk so gesagt, was dann halt sagt, weil jemand die Sachen vergibt, an das RIPE NCC gegeben. Die haben dann Angestellte, die dann halt nichts anderes machen, als Mails lesen, drin steht, ich brauch so und so viel IP-Adressen. Dann schauen sie, dass alles, ob das nach Policy-Konform so okay ist. Und wenn es okay ist, geben sie den Leuten dann die IP-Adressen.
Okay, das hört sich ja sehr gradlinig an, kaum kompliziert, wo man sagen muss, Beschlussfassung von mehreren Teilnehmern über Policy-Vorschläge sind wahrscheinlich große.
In Europa sind es, glaube ich, 5.000 Mitglieder und auf diesen Mailinglisten hast du so irgendwie, wenn es viel zu diskutieren gibt, sind das halt auch mal 50 oder 100 Mails am Tag. Und das ist schon, also wenn man damit halten will, ist das viel Mail lesen und in die Diskussion mitdiskutieren.
Ich muss jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch mal den boulevardesken Typen raushängen lassen, weil jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen, und das finde ich, also ich zumindest habe viel verstanden, erklärt, wie das Internet funktioniert auf einer Business-Ebene quasi. Jetzt sind ja die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club meistens auch damit beschäftigt, so Dinge auseinanderzunehmen oder zumindest mal hinzugucken und zu sagen, das ist aber da ein bisschen komisch und könnte uns möglicherweise mal auf die Füße fallen. Das habe ich jetzt bei den ganzen Sachen noch nicht so richtig gehört. Ist da etwa alles in Ordnung?
Eigentlich ist das alles super dezentral, aber es gibt natürlich überall irgendwie Haken an der Sache. Zum Beispiel gab es das mal vor mehreren Jahren. Da gab es also ein Großteil setzt halt irgendwie zum Beispiel Cisco-Router ein. Das ist eine Firma aus den USA, die stellt Netzwerkeräte her. Und wenn da ein bestimmtes Paket durchgeschickt wurde, haben die sich alle irgendwie intern aufgehangen und mussten resettet werden. Und das nannte man dann so den Flap Around the World, weil halt wirklich einmal um die ganze Welt rum, diese Router geflapt sind, da hat es dann einmal ordentlich gewackelt im Internet. Oder wenn halt ein so ein großer Exchange irgendwie mal Schluck auf hat, wo halt richtig viel rüberläuft in Europa, dann merkt man das schon. Aber so der Endkunde, der denkt dann am Ende mal, Facebook geht gerade nicht. Oder das YouTube Video legt, er lädt langsam. Also der Endkunde bekommt das in der Regel überhaupt nicht mit, was da passiert. Aber es ist so aufgebaut irgendwie, dass da eigentlich ein Ausfall, zum Beispiel, klassischer Fall, ein Bagger baggert so ein Glasfaserkabel kaputt. Innerhalb von Millisekunden ist der Traffic, dann wird woanders lang geleitet und fließt irgendwie von Düsseldorf nach Amsterdam über Düsseldorf, Berlin, Hamburg, Amsterdam.
Es ist ja aber trotzdem so, das sind alles zum allergrößten Teil Privatfirmen, die das machen, also Kapitalisten. Und es ist ja oft so, wenn das pure Business regiert, dass die Infrastruktur, die für solche Dinge verwendet wird, sehr hart kalkuliert ist, also nicht sehr ausfallsicher.
Ja, es gibt halt Firmen, die sehen sich daraus halt irgendwie, wir sind jetzt richtig gut und bei uns kostet alles ein bisschen mehr. Dafür haben wir irgendwie alles doppelt und dreifach gesichert. Und wenn jetzt irgendwie halb Europa stromlos ist, dann haben wir immer noch die andere Hälfte und können mit Amerika reden und so Sachen. Und das lässt sich dann einfach kosten, aber gibt's alles.
Du brauchst diese Art Reputation, dann auch wenn du Banken versorgst, wenn du da irgendwie so seriöse Businesspartner hast, kannst du da nicht einfach dahergehen und sagen, ich hab jetzt aller billigste Netze in mir grad zusammengeschlüppelt und dann ist es dann halt im Großteil der Zeit nicht erreichbar. Und aber auch die Geschichte des Internets, wie die so gewachsen ist, ist auch so, dass dort viele, viele Engineers immer mit dabei gewesen sind, irgendwie auch prinzipbedingt, weil dieses Thema auch dann ein bisschen trocken ist und erstaunlich wenig Leute, die einfach nur Geld dran verdienen wollten, im Laufe der Zeit gerade an der Kerninfrastruktur da beteiligt waren. Es gab viele, viel Konkurrenz einfach aus den Forschungsnetzen. Das heißt, dass zu der Zeit auch Wissenschaftler am meisten daran interessiert waren, ihre Universitäten, an denen ja auch die Computer dann standen, die wenigen, die miteinander hätten sprechen wollen, dass die dann auch schon untereinander dann eher dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Kabel verbuddelt werden und auch dort die verpeilten Wissenschaftler noch ans andere Ansprüche an die Verdrahtung hatten, als jemand, der jetzt seine Endkunden da anschließen möchte. Und auch viel kam ja aus der Post heraus. In Deutschland waren es damals nicht die Leute, die möglichst viel Geld verdienen wollten, sondern es saß dann auch mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen, die so ein beschnurbarteter Telekom früher Posttechnikgehalt hatte. Der wollte aber auch dann ein gutes Produkt abliefern, was dann halt auch ein bisschen teurer und ein bisschen unbeweglicher war. Aber so war die Geschichte des Netzes zumindest in Deutschland auch. Dann früher, dass sie das erklären, warum dann auch nicht ganz viele böse spielen. Aber es gibt jetzt auch, gerade bei den neueren CDN, gibt es auch welche, die dann wirklich mit harten Bandagen da reinmienen und sehen, dass da irgendwie noch Geld rauszusqueezen ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel diese, also die Redundanz, die man da halt baut, das als ausfallsicher ist, das rechnet sich halt einfach dadurch, weil wenn jetzt zum Beispiel in Berlin zweimal am Tag das Internet ausfällt oder sowas, dann dauert das irgendwie, dann gehen die Kunden ja automatisch weg, weil es doof ist.
Damit der S-Bahn tun sie es aber auch nicht.
Ja, nur bei der S-Bahn hat man glaube ich nicht so anruf, obwohl man könnte auf Helikopter oder Beam umsteigen, aber ja, beim Internet hat man halt die Wahl und wenn man scheiße ist, dann gehen halt die Leute da weg und man verliert Kunden. Deswegen schauen da alle schon, dass das einigermaßen gut ist und je nachdem, was für Kunden es sind, in dem Fall zum Beispiel bei Banken, da muss das alles irgendwie genau geregelt, dass die Glasfasern irgendwie es zwei Verbindungen zwischen den Rechenzentren gibt und an keiner Stelle dürfen sich die Kabel näher kommen als 100 Meter oder so. Also es ist ganz genau geregelt, wie das alles ist, damit das möglichst ausfallsicher läuft.
Also tatsächlich müssten wir sozusagen keine Angst um unser Internet haben, weil das kaputtzumachen ist schon eher schwierig.
Da gab's mal sogar einen, ich glaub, einen längeren Text darüber, wo irgendjemand meinte, was passiert wohl, wenn wir jetzt mit das Internet rum runternehmen wollen und dann hat er dann gesagt, ja dazu müsste man eigentlich nur irgendwie sich sämtliche Landestellen der Kabel, die unterseeisch ankommen. Die sind zwar versteckt, weiß keiner so genau, wo das ist, aber kriegt man raus und dann fing er an und dann wurde es plötzlich so ein zehnseitiger Round, was man alles gleichzeitig machen müsste, wie viele Leute man dafür aktivieren müsste. Wenn man 50.000 Leute gleichzeitig auf der Welt dazu anstiften könnte, das Internet ausschalten zu wollen, dann wäre das ganz einfach.
Gut, dann haben wir heute ausführlich geklärt, wie das Internet geldmäßig funktioniert. Wir haben zum Schluss noch einen Anrufer, der nämlich nicht genau weiß, wer es ist. Hallo und guten Abend. Und? Kannst du mir noch ganz kurz eine Frage beantworten?
Ja, na nicht eine Frage, sondern ich möchte deine Frage beantworten. Ich habe jetzt nicht mehr, ich arbeite bei einer Firma in Berlin, die ein Rechenzentrum hat. Ich habe jetzt leider nicht mehr genau die Stromkosten im Kopf, zumindest nicht vom Rechenzentrum, aber von den Verstärkerstationen. Kann man sich das so vorstellen, man braucht ja verschiedene Verstärkerstationen, 30 Stück sind das in Deutschland bei uns. Und dafür braucht jeder so im Schnitt 10.000 Euro nur an Strom.
Im Monat oder im Jahr? Im Monat. Wow! Wie viel Rechner habt ihr dann, in dem Rechenzentrum zu stehen?
Das ist schon eine ernste Menge. Das müsste ich jetzt durchzählen.
Du hast den Rechenzentrumsnamen mit einer 3 auf.
Gut, Fachleute unter sich, das wollen wir wahrscheinlich nicht im Radio genauer besprechen, worum es gerade geht.
Du bist gerade auf dem Weg von der Arbeit nach Hause.
Was hast du für ein Spleisgerät?
Ich würde vorschlagen, über diese Detail Details haltet ihr euch außerhalb. Tobias, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. Das war nochmal ein schöner Hausnummer, die es gut ist gehört zu haben. So, sehr schön. 10.000 Euro Luftwerte, okay, das ist schon viel Strom. So, Erdgeist, Kay, vielen Dank von Chaos Computer Club, die mir erklärt haben, wie das mit dem Geld ist. Ihr könnt, wenn ihr noch Fragen dazu habt oder Bemerkungen, die gerne ins Blog schreiben, chaosradio.de ist die Adresse, die funktioniert jetzt wieder und ist bestimmt total ausfallsicher.
Wir machen nach dem nächsten CDN raus, wenn jemand zu mir kommt, oder?
Ist klar. So, dann wünsche ich euch allen vielen Dank fürs Hiersein, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören euch von Radiogeräten. Wie gesagt, wenn ihr Fragen habt, stellt sie. Um nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, mein Name ist Markus Richter, macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.